President Trump says North Korea's
recent missile tests are not an issue
for him the president disagreed with his
own national security adviser and
Japan's prime minister at a news
conference in Tokyo overnight Ben Tracy
is traveling with the president in Tokyo
Ben good morning not the first time the
president has disagreed with his own
advisors exactly good morning the
president is here on this four-day state
visit mainly to meet Japan's new emperor
but given Japan's proximity to North
Korea his host can't be too pleased that
the president is saying he's not
personally bothered by North Korea's
latest missile test no I'm not I am
personally not the president dismissed
North Korea's tests earlier this month
of short-range missiles some of which
could be capable of hitting Japan it
doesn't matter all I know is that there
have been no nuclear tests they've been
no ballistic missiles going out he
directly contradicted his own national
security adviser John Bolton and
Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a who
say Kim Jong Un's tests violate United
Nations Security Council resolutions I
view it differently I view it as a man
perhaps he wants to get attention and
perhaps none who knows the president
also sided with the North Korean
dictator on another issue former Vice
President Joe Biden who the North
Koreans recently called a low IQ
individual he probably is based on his
record I think I agree with him on that
Joe Biden was a disaster so I'm not a
fan earlier in the day at Japan's
Imperial Palace President Trump with the
center of attention the first world
leader to meet newly installed Japanese
Emperor Nara hito that was a great honor
that's a big thing 202 years that's the
last time this has happened
Prime Minister Abe a has used this state
visit to continue his charm offensive
with President Trump it seems to be
working the president delayed tariffs he
planned to impose on Japan and seemed
optimistic the two sides can work out a
trade agreement this weekend Abe a took
the president to see a sumo wrestling
match something mr. Trump has called
fascinating the president presented in
nearly 70 pound Presidents Cup trophy to
the winner the two leaders also played a
round of golf complete with a selfie
followed by a lunch of double
cheeseburgers we have the best
relationship that we've ever had with
Japan and we're going to keep it that
way now president Trump does plan to
visit a u.s. naval base here in Japan
tomorrow to greet US service members
before he heads back to Washington
Anthony then the president also talked
about escalating tensions with Iran does
Japan play a role in that relationship
well they could prime minister obby said
that he could act as a mediator of sorts
between Iran and the US and president
Trump today said that he supports that
idea the president also went out of his
way to say that despite some of these
talks of war that the u.s. does not seek
regime change Ben Tracy in Tokyo thanks
Ben